oh yes time for some more of that Prime
Time chainsaw man as in today's video we
are diving back into and completing the
second Arc to part two of the series
that being the war devil Arc this video
here follows the Rex Lee after the end
of part two's introduction Arc where we
were introduced to asamitaku and her new
soul mate the beautifully arrogant War
Devol obviously if you do enjoy content
like this and want to see more then make
sure you hit the Subscribe button and be
sure to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with pushing my content
to a bunch of new amazing people plus a
fair chainsaw main manga giveaway in
this video so be sure to keep an eye out
for that in a few minutes but anyway
enough of that let's get into the
contents so as we start back out in this
series we find people celebrating and
walking around and their top tier
chainsaw man merge while at the same
time various citizens are interviewed by
a news Outlet about chainsaw man it's
pretty 50 50 in regards to what they
think about him some are extremely
enthusiastic about him whereas on the
other hand other people doubt his
intentions giving reasons such as
getting rid of jobs for devil Hunters
claiming that he's an American Style op
that he's too destructive that he is too
popular or that he eats people and their
pets dingy who just happens to be among
those civilians being interviewed
attempts to make chainsmen look better
dude literally goes on a full tangent
about how frankly it's not possible that
chainsaw man ate the cat from the other
day but everybody in his school loves
him and then he bits he's a seriously
great guy yet instantly the film crew
turn around and are like yeah let's cut
that out he spoke far too much as the
crowd now goes back to screaming out
boy's name nobody actually recognizes he
is who they are talking about but dingy
stands there proud like the legend he is
everyone's favorite 25 year old repeat
high school student Yoshida then rolls
up on the same as everybody else screams
for chainsaw man but once he tries to
speak to dingy who stands there proudly
dingy doesn't seem to recognize him at
all which I'm honestly wondering if he
simply forgot who Yoshida is or is he
trying to actually distance himself from
anyone who was previously at the bureau
just an idea after Yoshida is like
literally oof bro that hurts remember
when you had all those assassins after
you dingy blatantly lies and says that
he never remembers it happening
following a short awkward conversation
the duo ends up making their way to a
cafe denji orders a massive feed and
while sitting there with Yoshida notices
that he's wearing the same uniform as
him Yoshida blatantly lies blowing it
off as a coincidence that they attend
the same school dingy prods further
though and asks Yoshida if he's actually
stalking him to which he explains that
technically he isn't wrong and in fact
belongs to part of an organization not
the evil type that you'd usually find in
manga but instead the group is simply
seeking to protect dinghy from having
his secret identity revealed to the
public allowing him to live a peaceful
life elaborating more he explains that
pretty much he'll be in a load of
trouble if dingy's true identity is
revealed to the public once more kind of
like how we know the Assassins showed up
during the international assassin's Arc
and people knew chainsaw man was in
Japan but they didn't necessarily know
the human face just like the chainsaw
man won and the clothes that he was
wearing at the time anyway Yoshida tells
dinji that if he doesn't listen and his
identity is exposed he won't allow him
to eat any more cake disgusting with the
idea though of not being allowed any of
life's luxuries the Indian State slams
his hand down onto the table cutting the
cake open with his beer hand while Genji
stuffs his gullet Yoshida is left
utterly flabbergasted with a change in
events he tries explaining that if he
leads the cat out of the bag using a cat
as per usual chainsaw man the life he
has now will fall to pieces confused he
asks why he's fighting has changed for
me in any way and finally as our boy
scuffs down all of his food he Reveals
His current goal telling Yoshida that he
wants his identity to be revealed
because once the Secret's out all of the
ladies will be over him Yoshida sits
there for a moments and utter
bewilderment trying to think about what
he replied but simply can't deny the
fact that dingy is probably right
skipping away from the horndog we are
flying over to our neurodivergent queen
as yodu pounds who fists and screams
into a pillow Thoth that she and ASA
were saved by chainsaw man obviously
this is because the goal is literally to
take out chainsaw man ASA asks why the
ward ever once chainsaw man dead so
badly to watch Yo opens up about how
during the first fight were chainsaw man
alongside the other four Horseman her
body was partially consumed Awakening
her and explaining why there had been no
major Wars since the world war though
this is partially due to chainsaw man
also consuming nuclear weapons and the
World War II devil as we learned in the
control devil Arc Euro also opens up
about being worried that since War has
been relegated to just being a media
subject everyone would soon forget about
the concept of it and she would continue
Awakening to the point that she would
cease to exist ASA asks if Yoda was
afraid of being forgotten but quickly
realizes that the previously raging
devil had already fallen asleep laying
there herself ASA thinks that for the
longest time she didn't care if she died
but now she's happy she hasn't and
thanks chainsaw man for saving her
before falling asleep as well the next
day and all my Lord didn't you I mean
fujimodo you have to chill bro this is
some of the craziest stuff ever at
school dingy absolutely loving life is
shown to be acting as a seed for a young
lady only to be called Away by Yoshida
then she explains that every 10 minutes
he pretends to be a cheer he gets paid
10 Yen but if he's held up for much
longer he'll have to refund her your
shooter returns denji's student ID card
explaining that he dropped it during the
fight with the Cockroach devil and he
won't let chainsaw man's identity get
exposed as he knows for a fact Genji
purposely left it there in the hopes
that he'd be identified as the devil
itself dingy tries to back away so he
can go back to making Bankers a cheer
only for Yoshida to turn around and
actually pay him 10 000 Yen if he stays
and acts as his seeds he then asks
stingy if he's trying to expose his
identity in order to get a girlfriend to
what she confirms Yoshida then offers to
find him a girlfriend if he promises to
not expose his identity to the public
and dingy is instantly like okay
introduce me to her please if she did
quickly asks what his type is and dingy
in the most down bad statement of ivory
explains that his type is a girl who's
desperate for a boyfriend and your she'd
have been on this same mental plane as
myself and certainly realizes that he
knows the perfect girl who seemingly
fits at exact description flashing
outside probably till the top of the
school where ASA usually hangs out there
Yoshida brings out up that Assa was
saved by chains for men and introduces
dingy as a huge fan of the Chainsaw man
who'd love to talk to her ASA explains
that she used to actually hate chainsaw
man bringing up several reasons as to
why with dingy refuting each claim every
time with an increasing frustration ASA
claims that dingy wouldn't know what
changed women is like as it's not like
he could possibly be him again she
continues dogging on the chainsaw man
with dingy eventually getting to the
point where he boils over and confesses
that he knows all of this information
because he is indeed the chainsaw man
continuing to brag about knowing exactly
what chainsaw man is thinking because he
is him he asks her if she gets it now
not believing him in the slightest slow
and with Yoshida literally face palming
over dingy stupidness USA calls him a
loser and instantly leaves twitch's DG
screams after her Yoshida remarks that
nobody would believe him if he continued
acting so flagrantly okay before we go
any further though fat chainsaw Man
manga giveaway that I was talking about
at the beginning of the video you see
these three chainsaw man volumes here
volume 3 10 and 11 well I accidentally
bought double ups and if you want to get
a chance to win these three here then
leave a comment down below with your
favorite moment throughout this series
and your Twitter handle so that I can
follow you back if you do learn when it
comes to like who's going to win the
giveaway or how I'm going to do the
giveaway or winning and all that kind of
jazz I'll just use a random comment
picker and recorder and then upload it
probably probably over on my Twitter or
something like that or put it in one of
my like next videos coming up and then
you know like reach out to that person
through the comment section or then
through Twitter that's why I want you
guys to leave your like handles there
and all that kind of stuff but anyways
enough of that Merry Christmas and back
to the video so having left dingy on the
roof Yoda was enraged that she didn't
outright murk dinchy for admitting to
being chainsaw man I saw on the other
hand who straight up calls Yodo an idiot
for actually believing him is still
unconvinced explaining how it makes no
sense for him to be a mega fan as well
as the actual chainsaw man what she kind
of like actually has a point on there
later on and after school ends for the
day good all demands there utter hunts
for another devil in order to get into
the devil Hunters club though she says
that she's going to visit Yuko instead
and raged yodu thread into her and asks
if she's even thought of a way to find
chainsaw man by the way her wonderful
like people around have noticed her and
realized that she's just talking aloud
to absolutely no one us retorts she
states that if they lead a devil to the
school he would reveal himself anyways
standing there and wondering how to
actually draw a devil to the school I
supplies towards arrogant side calling
her the smart one and leaving her with a
plan while she visits Yuko watching you
walk away yodu thinks that perhaps you
really can tame her once arriving at
yoku's house and after being surprised
for being praised by her friend they sit
with each other telling secrets you
could admit to reading self-help books
on how to make friends while ASA
confesses that she wet herself during
class one day which causes Yuko to
literally cool over into a seat laughing
about how the class played along to us
as terrible sweat excuse Yuko then and a
complete change of Direction confesses
that she actually took out her neighbor
for gambling away his wealthy dance
unable to even form a proper sentence in
response USA just keeps repeating what
the hell and a non nonchalant manner
probably not believing her however after
one of yuko's other neighbors says hi
and then leaves she offers to show USA
where the deceased man is now asking if
she's joking though Yuko simply replies
that it's out back as she wants to see
it but Usher wisely declines but holy I
would be freaking out right now if it's
all of a sudden have an IRL like choose
your friends wisely here people anyways
saying it's fine either way as they are
best friends because they revealed each
other's closest Secrets YooHoo promises
that she won't tell anyone about how she
paid herself or about how she took out
the teacher plus president and has made
a contract with the devil inside of her
named yodu stay seen that there is no
secrets between the two yuku then
reveals that she also made a deal with
the Justice devil yesterday granting her
the ability to read vines in order to be
able to understand those around her as
she just doesn't get people then on top
of that she reveals that all of this is
to help us sir as the two are now best
friends and yuku decides that she will
handle her best friend's bullying
problem later on when walking through
the streets yodel and asset talk about
Yoku being evil other wonders about how
Yoku is going to solve her bullying
problem at school telling her to stop
the stupidness though yuru explains that
she's obviously going to take out all of
the classmates that bully her ASA puts
forward the idea of talking Yoku out of
it but yodu disagrees asking her how
she's even going to do there when her
body already belongs to her Yoda instead
plans on destroying Goku as soon as she
reaches skull I set his shock and
strongly disagrees however according to
yaru this would lead chainsaw man
straight to them and even if it doesn't
it would get them into the devil Hunters
Club through taking out Yoku elsewhere
Goku though their absolute Maniac is
seeing burning something while
maniacally repeating that she'll save us
as soon and get rid of all of the bad
guys for her moving into the next day
Goku who woke up slightly late greets
people on her final journey to school
yet as you all probably saw coming as
she makes her way through the school
hallways she is confronted by no one
other than the war devil who was in
control of Us's body now trying to buy
time through talking Yuko brings up how
it's weird that the chainsaw man goes to
school as it doesn't even prevent
bullying here she then considers that
perhaps he only fights other Devils
putting that aside for now though Goku
says that they can fight once she gets
rid of all of the bullies in the school
obviously yodu doesn't agree to this as
she thinks Joker will run away as soon
as she's finished her job yohoo says
that you can't beat me though if we
fight anyways as I can read your every
move and Society in the battle to begin
though Guru asks Yoku to bait her but
reminds her that us will be taken out as
well frustrated as she loves Usher but
hates yoru more than anything Yoku
ultimately decides to transform into a
devil form and certainly Yoko shoots out
a bunch of Limbs into the tight hallway
yodu Dodges though between the flying
projectiles managing to get a few
attacks off with a pencil that she
turned into a blade taking a bit of
damage Yoku yells cool but you're in my
way and goes to hit Yodo as she floats
in the air having been sent shooting
back yolu lands in a classroom and panic
and selling in shoes as the students
yell and run for their lives catching a
glimpse of the devil a random teacher
makes an emergency announcement facing
that a dangerous devil has appeared on
the campus urging students to escape
through the nearest Escape Route join
the Panic some students are seen
questioning whether this is a drill or
not well those eggs are utterly stunned
as the devil itself appears directly
behind them and says this indeed is not
a drill turning these students exclaim
and run for their lives all the while
the devil Walks Behind them asking who
put the chicken in the locker the other
day once spotting the girls yodu luckily
appears from behind and throws a pencil
which morphs into a spear to distract
her but sadly the devil blocks it and
says that she told her that she can
breed every single one of her moves Yoku
goes on to throw the spear directly into
one of the students trying to flee and
knocks down another one smashing her
against the wall fortunately while she
is looking for the last devil a devil
Hunter appears the devil Hunter
introduces himself as Sega from the
devil Hunter club and says he'll buy
time for the real Hunters arrive poor
dude doesn't know what he just got into
Yoku yells that he doesn't want to hurt
innocent randoms but proceeds to attack
him either way luckily it turns out our
boy is a damn Prodigy and he showcases
some slick moves being able to smash
Yuko in the stomach running up behind
his boy for you arrives instantly aiming
in shooting his crossbow at the base in
front of him while the three fight a
female hunter from the school's Club
Dives in and slices one of the monsters
horns off with three baby hunters and
yaru all beating down on the devil she
talks a bit of smack asking her if she
was going to die before the chainsaw man
even got here Yoku who obviously wasn't
trying to hurt the innocent says that
since they have ganked upon her she has
no other choice sadly she then proceeds
to slam them all with their orbiting
limbs seemingly taking out all three of
the wannabe Hunters she then goes on to
warn yoru that you'll end up like them
as she already knows how Yodo has laid
traps for her and set up various weapons
throughout the school in an attempt to
stop her she says that she is going to
save us from her bullies but Yeti
replies that she has one more idea
though before giving her body back to
ASA who as you'd imagine goes on to
plead with Yoku asking her to stop
confronting the justice evil ASA tries
to raise him with her but Yoku states
that she only has taken out all of the
bad ones according to her this will
serve as a lesson to all of the bullies
in Japan and in bullying altogether ASA
snaps at this though and asks Yodo to
instruct her about how to make a weapon
to which he explains that she needs to
touch something that belongs to her and
call its name Yoku yells that there is
no point to it but as it goes on to tear
a few uniform and say super strong
uniform sword as a result her uniform
tears off from around her and transforms
into a huge rectangular sword leaving
ASA standing there in her bathing suit
apart from showing off her
well-maintained body she goes on to
threaten Yoku and gives her a final
warning Yoku goes on to explain to her
thus eradicating Bully's plan and how
she is trying to become a symbol of
Justice like chainsaw man also says that
it all makes no sense and asks what she
gave up in exchange for the devil's
Powers but Yoku simply replied that
there was no giving instead they only
received Yoku says that when she was
given this power she was also given a
hearth that shines with the light of
Justice along with Earth after saying
this she moves on to kill the final
bully and asks ASA to put on some
clothes passing her off as a simple
nuisance she doesn't have time for ASA
runs forward and tries to cut the
devil's leg but Yoku easily whacks the
sword out of your hand watching this
yaru mocks her calling you awake while
Yoku simultaneously mocks her as well
however before she could finish her
sentence she's all of a sudden cut into
a few hundred sushi-sized pieces and yes
surprisingly ASA was the one who took
her down while they saw that she had
created from her Tam school uniform it's
explained that the reason her weapon was
so randomly broken in terms of strength
is because your mum had given her that
uniform before she passed away man
tatsuki always out here blowing my puny
monkey mind with these god-tier weapons
the war devil can create or just swords
in general created by Devils throughout
the series they're all just so well done
like they would look so damn freaking
good anyways obviously ASA didn't want
to have to do this and it's just
heartbroken over what happened to her
friend ujimo remains of the Justice
devil to try trying to live on suddenly
a mysterious girl arrives asking if she
wants to save her obviously as a reply
to firmatively and the girl looking down
on her revealing also her Spiral Eye
States anything for my little sister I
said shocked to hear this while at the
same time outside the building the devil
Hunters arrive on the scene asking the
public where the devil is however there
ain't no need to try and find her as all
of a sudden the building explodes with
the now oversized revived Justice devull
Goku now resurrected takes a moment to
remember what she was up to and then
continues to Rampage completely
destroying a few levels of his school
with a massive lashing attack two boys
attack her from behind but she taunts
them and easily defeats them both
suddenly though she stops as she sees
Usher lying on the ground badly wounded
freaking out about who did this she
picks up a random girl blames her and is
about to crush her before being stopped
by the legend himself dingy who just
showed up on the Block looking over she
asks him to mind his own business but
dingy who's trying to not blow his cover
realizes that a superhero can't stand
around idly during an emergency
screaming at him to leave Yoku swings at
him you tell boy got that speed now and
quickly manages to dodge the strike
before transforming and slicing the
adjuster's devil's arm open screaming
again but this time in pure fear Yoko
was surprised and tells him to stay away
while sending a plethora of expanding
limbs in his Direction danger yells that
chainsaw man is here to save the day
while falling down and dodging all of
his strikes stunt on why she can't land
an attack Yoku tries to read his mind
but is completely perplexed after
learning that dingy isn't even thinking
about the damn fight instead man is
solely focused on how to expose his own
identity as they change the man while
making it or seem natural as we float
there about the two Devils fighting it
shoots away for a second over to a base
in Arthur waking up after being knocked
out standing up yodu's personality takes
a hole as you see chainsaw man now
standing directly in front of her as it
picks up yoku's lyric and yelled Goku
League sword creating a damn sword out
of her leg before asking change to men
if he remembers her obviously she
doesn't realize it's dingy and dingy
doesn't have a clue who the war devil is
obviously our boy though being the perv
he is looks at her body and the new
bottom anyways then randomly the girl
dingy had just saved Rises out of the
devil's body instantly the girl starts
freaking out thinking that he's going to
eat you as well but dingy clarifies that
he saves people not eat them as he is
human on the inside suddenly Usher leaps
into action and is about to hit chainsaw
man but once he swings hits nothing and
finds out that he vanished she gets
infuriated not being able to find him
and thinks that chainsaw man doesn't
deem her worthy yet in actual reality
dingy was cut out of a reveal by
yoshida's tentacles so fast yodu didn't
even realize what happened over with
octo boy Yoshida tells dingy he's
hopeless and they did stop him by force
if he had two now I want a completely
different turn of events like we're
leaving all this battle entirely and
going to sleep we find USA running down
an Alleyway listed with the dead
chickens so many chickens in fact that
she can't help herself to not step on
them then why running into the darkness
that's in front of her she wakes back up
in a terrified sweat getting up out of
bed she then grabs a drink of water and
walks to go back to sleep but then
mysteriously her doorbell rings scared
utter asks who's there and the person
outside quickly apologizes for showing
up so late at night I said it's about to
open the door but the person replies
don't open it and identifies herself as
Yoku she says that she managed to escape
but has turned herself into the devil
and if Assa opens the door she might try
and eat her user being a Divergent self
has zero want to sustain a normal life
and opens the door anyway revealing
yoku's hybrid form have you opened the
door USA asks if she wants to eat her to
watch Yoku says a little bit and chooses
not to look at her to avoid Temptation
she says that she's here to say goodbye
as she is going to a distant relative
who she believes to be a devil hunter in
search of a way to turn her back to a
human Yoku clarifies that she made a
deal with the Justice devil not to save
her but to be like chainsaw man and make
people like her which is an extremely
interesting form of a contract and they
personally wonder if the wording matters
in terms of like how powerful you can be
in the contract anyways she goes on to
say that she's the worst and everything
she did was meaningless as she tries to
stop Yoku from walking away but I'm
assuming the Justice's side unknowingly
hits her with her tail she says that she
didn't intend to hurt her and just
wanted to give her a proper goodbye
since she was her first friend she
warned her to not make a deal with the
Justice devil like her then once again
goes to leave but ASA stops her and
tells her to just wait one second coming
back out of her place it's revealed that
like when they first became friends as
he wants to hand over a pair of shoes to
her since she noticed Yoku was barefoot
being stubborn as well Yoku refuses but
us to say that if she doesn't need them
she can sell them and if she doesn't
sell them she can just throw them away
Yahoo laughs a little realizing that she
was the one who first did that super
cringe line and certainly they both
crack up laughing at how dumb they
sounded yet still somehow our girl has
the realization and can see that she
truly is the worst everything that she
has also done has caused people a lot of
pain and here she is now laughing about
it
after sharing that sweet moment together
ASA tells her that she better bring
those shoes back someday to watch Yahoo
promises her that she will but this is
chainsaw man and not my hero Academia
and as Yoku is jumping from building to
building wishing that she could read
Birds Minds we hear her a mysterious
noise similar to a chainsaw man but see
USA slightly restless and beard as dingy
also sleeps soundly with neuter yet
somehow Yoku has been completely
destroyed by something that must have
resembled the chainsaw man as someone
with a similar figure stands atop this
skyscraper holding on to the ankle of
yuko's leg
so skipping forward a few days I would
imagine to like the moment they can
return to school which was in bad shape
and is still under repairs as it was
almost completely destroyed by a devil
the other day while at school as I
suddenly remembers the mysterious girl
who called her my little sister and asks
yodu if she was her sister but yoru
declines calling the mysterious girl a
mad woman which is just like the worst
lie I've seen from yodu so far but
anyways anyways thinking internally USA
assumes that she brought back Yoku and
wonders if the girl was the real Justice
devil walking through this school she
encounters the devil Hunters club which
fought Yoku and lost a bunch of its
members instantly she notices the
mysterious girl she was talking about is
actually a part of the devil Hunter Club
the council president though looks like
a fighter out of fight Island introduces
himself as Haruka is and says that the
devil Hunters Club lost two members the
other day during the conflict yet he
says that akoku the initial dude who
showed up and stunted on the Justice
devil he told him how well us have
fought any conflict and offers a
response in the club momentarily yodu
takes control saying that she had
changed woman and was a member of the
club and asks if Haruka knew him
confidently the dude laughs and then
goes on to reveal his chest which is the
same pull starter as dingy therefore
revealing himself to be the chainsaw man
of course we know that the man is a
complete imposter and also he most
likely was the person atop the building
with Yoku who has a similar figure to
the chainsaw man she gets Furious and
leaves saying see you around chainsaw
man as they walk past them ASA asks yodu
if the guy really is chainsaw man and
Yoda replies that the starter proves it
I still wonder is why he added himself
like that and also why yodu didn't lash
out to fight him yo says that she could
barely beat Yoku by herself so there's
no way that she could go up against
chains for men currently and win she
says that she needs a strong weapon and
commands ASA to conjure a weapon even
stronger than a uniform sword also murk
her standing there utter agree saying
that she'll make you the strongest
weapon ever and beat chainsaw man to
which Jody replies that she's randomly
obedient today ASA knows though that the
sooner she is done with chainsaw man the
sooner the warrior will leave her body
as as long as yodu inhabits her everyone
around her will be miserable Isaac says
that she'll do anything to make that
happen and even turn someone into a
weapon she starts to look at people on
the busy street below her while yoru
says that she doesn't have to
technically use a human as if she has
something more important than her it
will work suddenly a cat walks in which
is like NADA you better not use the damn
care and Yoda suggested turn it into a
weapon as it says though that she'd
rather use a human than a cat and
instead starts to look for a criminal or
some other low-life person yo says that
that won't work though is creating a
powerful weapon requires powerful guilt
instead she suggests that she picks
someone between a cat and a criminal
looking down at all of the humans below
her she suddenly sees dingy who looks
like the biggest weed there plus on top
of that dude is literally picking up
rubbish off these streets which you know
is like pretty good of him other things
that he is utterly a loser and an idiot
but still a good person at heart she
absorbs further following home and finds
out that he has rolling new cigarettes
out of these cigarette butts that he
just picked up and settling them to
homeless people for a higher price
claiming them to be American premiums
having a change of heart also thinks
that he is indeed a bad person trying to
rip off the homeless but still not bad
enough to deserve death basically he is
what she's looking for Yoda confirms the
same he's the right choice use him to
defeat chainsaw man and get her body
back obviously not even realizing that
this is actually chainsaw man anyways
while thinking about Yoku yodu tells her
to think of it as a necessary evil to
put an end to a nightmare later on
having caught up and found denji they
have a short conversation as dingy
recognizes her as the girl who doesn't
like chainsaw man he says he is really
busy and doesn't have the time to talk
but ASA asks if he's free tomorrow dingy
brushes her off saying that he's busy
the next day though but as we know our
dude is a freaking sucker for melon and
on a second lock asks why she asked him
what she blushes like crazy and
awkwardly asks dingy for a date man
probably just had fireworks go off
inside of his brain and as he stands
there he simply replies with yes
skipping forward to the day of the date
and looking hella cute as it has seen
preparing for a date with denji while
yodu chills in the corner repeatedly
mocking her she doubt she'll be able to
seduce him and turn him into a weapon
but USA says it's easy as boys fall for
anyone who'd even show them a fraction
of a good time she says Yodo won't
understand as she's a devil and that USA
believes she's pretty damn cute cute
enough to make dingy fall head over
heels for her out on the date now with a
Duo at the aquarium ASA continuously
talks about the various kinds of fish
there or dingy listens however our boys
are monkey brain and gets utterly
frustrated with all of the info asking
her to stop so they can move on and see
those Penguins ASA is like definitely
somewhat neurodivergent and nice I'm
saying that she has planned their date
properly to the point they'll have to
wait here for at least another 10
minutes dingy who's like completely
shocked with her dominating attitude
gives in and now USA starts talking and
length about starfish moving forward
through the aquarium our boy once gets
frustrated and asks her to visit those
Penguins now yet once again as it
repeats the same same thing as before
and says dingy will have to listen about
starfish for at least another 30 minutes
as she continues explaining starfish she
thinks that dingy should be falling head
over heels for her by now but cutting in
on her conversation dingy plays with her
wanting to see those beautiful penguins
and as you'd imagine gigian tries to
make him stick with a fun plan but he
disagrees saying that he'll experienced
the entire aquarium in his own way then
storm enough to see those elusive
Penguins Blown Away with a tune of
events I just can't understand why but
yoru once again taunts her and says that
maybe it's because she's a total boar
and not only dingy but even she was
bored the entire time USA was lecturing
as he ends up yelling at the devil
exclaiming that she is right that she
studied up for ages on all of these
facts and these silly ass devils are the
real wars jyoto actually gives in and
asks her to go after dingy but ASA who
can't stop raging out screams she did
everything right suddenly someone again
appears telling her that she indeed
wasn't wrong at all man the the skills
drip and the uniform goes so damn hard
and I just realize now you can visibly
see her earring trigger switch anyways
the girls say she is right and then she
doesn't know the first thing about right
and Wrongs menacingly looking at her she
states that there is one thing and what
she's wrong about she can't turn dingy
into a weapon she tells user who only
does the right thing that she can't turn
a human into a weapon ASA is visibly
sharp asking a girl how in the world she
knows her powers taking off her cap the
girl introduces herself as the war
Devil's big sister the infamous famine
devil and asks Usher to call her Fanny
obviously this is the third of the Four
Horsemen and oh my Lord having caught up
now we got this so much earlier than I
actually expected anyways Yaro asks USA
to not listen to her but suddenly both
femi and yoru disappear ASA exclaims
yodu's name but femi only responds she
has separated yodu from her temporarily
and that USA isn't leaving the aquarium
until she abandons her mortality and
converts dingy into a weapon dingy
himself having been walking around
unable to find the Penguins appears back
and says that we've got an emergency he
explains that the aquarium isn't this
big and he can't find a way out no
matter how far he walks while using
gasps in response Digi mutters that pain
in the butts back from hell as they look
around and see a stretching hallway with
seemingly no end
so you know perfect spot I think to end
the second Arc of Chainsaw man part 2 or
the war devil Arc here obviously there
is so much more we are going to let
learn from here on out but I think a lot
of the next Arc will either involve
before Horsemen the famine devil or
maybe even The Eternity devil Arc and
part 2 will be a longer Arc like it was
in part one by the way remember to leave
your comments down below and put your
like Twitter ads in them as well just to
make sure that I can reach out to you
somehow or another or just keep an eye
on like the comment section of this
video so after I get back from my
holiday in January I can reach out to
you guys and let you know who's won the
three manga volumes anyway enough of it
if you are new around here make sure you
hit the Subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with pushing my stuff
to a bunch of new amazing people but for
now it's been your professional
degenerate dear Volo bye